Speaker 1: a lot has been made, a lot has
been said, a lot has been suggested about
the sentences that are coming down and being
handed down or the manner with which the January
six insurrectionists are being treated in
federal jail.
There is no federal bail system like there
is in state courts or local municipalities.
It's either you're you're you're you're released
on your own recognizance or you're put on
house arrest with an ankle monitor or you're
remanded to custody until trial.
And a federal judge, this is a political headline,
judge suggests feds are too lenient toward
Jan six defendants.
The chief judge of the federal court in Washington
raised questions about why pleading guilty
to a misdemeanor was permitted to resolve
certain cases.
Now, many of you don't know who I have, but
I happen to have a close connection to the
January six insurrection.
My wife and co-host of my podcast, I doubt
it.
One of them, this Dingess, was my wife's high
school boyfriend.
Speaker 3: I just I just got in the way.
I just got in the Capitol building.
I was the first one to hop down into the chamber
and I was the first one to see you.
Speaker 1: Nancy Pelosi, that bitch
Speaker 4: her she's she's a traitor.
She's treasonous.
Speaker 1: Save the condolences.
This was a long time ago.
It's not like she escaped some cult relationship.
They were kids.
But this is the kind of of people that I was
surrounded by growing up in Idaho.
Josiah Colt, who also related to this story,
is being allowed all kinds of plea deals for
his promises to turn state's evidence and
and testify against his conspirators.
There are absolutely deals being made, and
I think this judge has an important perspective.
A federal judge suggested Monday that federal
prosecutors were being too lenient in their
handling of cases stemming from the storming
of the United States Capitol as lawmakers
were convening on January six to certify Joe
Biden's victory in the presidential race.
Beryl Howell, the chief judge of the federal
court in Washington, deluged with more than
550 prosecutions from the capital riot, raised
questions about why some defendants were being
permitted to resolve their criminal cases
by pleading guilty to a misdemeanor.
And why the amount of money prosecutors are
seeking to recover through those plea deals
was based on a relatively paltry estimate
of about one point five million in damages
caused by the rioters.
Howl aired her doubts during what was expected
to be a routine morning hearing to take the
guilty plea of a capital riot defendant Glen
Kreuz of Colorado Springs, Colorado.
Kreuz was arrested in February on charges
that he and another man, Terry Lindsy illegally,
entered the Capitol building on January 6th.
Final paragraph here.
Under a deal with prosecutors, Kreuz was seeking
to plead guilty to a single misdemeanor charge
of parading or picketing in the capital that
carries a maximum sentence of six months in
jail and a fine of up to 5000.
To overuse the term again, this does not pass
the smell test.
They weren't just there picketing.
It wasn't a protest.
They weren't holding a parade.
The intent of everyone there who entered the
capital was to disrupt the counting of votes,
the certification of the 20 20 presidential
election.
To overturn those results, to strike and stoke
fear in a terroristic manner into the hearts
and minds of of legislators tasked with constitutionally
tasked with certifying the vote.
Electing in a peaceful transfer of power,
the next president of the United States, so
I'm with Barel Howle, I agree hard questions
need to be asked as we delve into these particular
prosecutions.
They shouldn't.
Prosecutors should not be too quick to allow
plea deals that will lighten the results and
the consequences for these insurrectionists